Friends, delegates and fellow Americans,...
...I humbly and gratefully accept your nomination...
...for the presidency of the United States.
Together, we will lead our party back to the White House,...
...and we will lead our country back to safety, prosperity and peace.
My plan will begin with safety at home,...
...which means safe neighborhoods, secure borders...
...and protection from terrorism.
There can be no prosperity without law and order.
My message is that things have to change, and they have to change right now.
We will make America strong again.
We will make America proud again.
We will make America safe again,...
...and we will make America great again.
God bless you and good night.
I love you!